- Hi.
My name is John-Francis Ellis.
I'm here in my shop
near Jewett, Ohio.
I'll give you guys a tour.
This piece of rusty metal here
is the forge I actually bring
out to, like, fairs
and demonstrations and stuff.
It'll burn coal or charcoal.
You just run air through there,
and it works really good.
This is actually
a blower I made.
It's got, I think,
a half-horsepower motor there.
I've experimented with
different kinds of forges
that ran on, like, diesel
and stuff,
I need a bigger blower,
so I built that.
And then this is where I have
some of the stuff I've made
hanging up--
tomahawks I made,
some knives, a spearhead.
This is a crappy sword
that I made a long time ago.
Not my proudest piece of work,
but hey, I made it,
so I'm hanging it up in here.
- I'm JD.
This is my home forge
in Elmira, New York.
This is kind of
my main forging area--
anvils and hammers
and all that.
My forge right there
is just fire brick
with a ceramic liner,
running off propane,
that way with the fire brick,
I can move things around
how I want.
Just a work table
out here for hot work,
or whatever I need to do.
- Right here is actually
a flamethrower that I built.
It runs off diesel.
You pressurize it with like
a bike pump through here.
It's made out of
a fire extinguisher,
so it's kind of ironic,
I guess.
But it actually works
pretty well.
Usually I can get, like,
a 20-foot flame or so with it.
And then moving on
to the belt grinder.
This is--
I actually built
this belt grinder myself.
It's got a motor off--
I believe,
it's an old air compressor.
It's like a one-horsepower
electric motor.
I can untighten that
and put
different attachments in
if I need, like,
a wheel out front
and this also goes up and down
so I can adjust everything.
Definitely speeds up the work
here in the shop.
I think that's pretty much it,
so there you go.
That's my shop.
- On the same wall I try to
keep all my grinding stuff.
So I have a chop saw.
That speeds up
metal cutting a lot,
compared to cutting it by hand,
which I used to do.
My belt grinder--
I was gonna buy one,
but they're stupid-expensive,
so I made one.
Then a smaller belt grinder.
Couple bench grinders.
And then over on this wall
I have all the woodworking
equipment;
wood lathe, band saw,
drill press,
and then my metal lathe
I just got a year or two ago
and restored that.
So that's my forge.
Thanks for coming by.